ايه وصار معروف عنك شخصيا انك من
المعارضين لاختيار رشي سوناك رئيسا
للوزراء ما الذي يدعم نظريتك لماذا يعني
انت معارض الاختياره
بالكامل ولكن نعتقل بان العمليه كانت خطا
لو فاز بشكل نديمقراطي ما كنتم ساقطه ضده
ولكن حقيقه خسارته في حملته السابقه ضد
هي دامت ل 45 يوما وهو
شارك ولم يفوز هذا يظهر بان الحزب لا
يحترمه الاصوات العضويه
فقد رفضوا همم الانتخابات او في صناديق
الاقتراع هو خلال شهر هنا اصبح رئيسا
وزراء همم
يخالف ولا الديمقراطيه ولكن
للحزب ولكن اني اعتقد ان الامر بشكل اخر
بدات حديثك
بنظره سريعه على الوضع السياسي العام في
بريطانيا
لو توضح لي اكثر كيف ترى المشهد السياسي
في بريطانيا على المدى المندور اولها
الذين ازمه اقتصاديه عميقه ولن يكون مساله
حلها وعلى ريش ان يتخذ قرارات لن تعجب
الشعب هل سيصمد مع اتخاذ هذه القرارات
التي لم تعجب الشعب امراه مثل ثلاث اشهر
من فعل ذلك ولكنها كانت تحصل على دعم كبير
جدا من الحزب فالسؤال هل الريشه لديه دعم
كبير من الحزب اذا ما اتخذ قرارات ستصب في
مصلحه البلاد البعيد ولكنها لم تعجب الشعب
لا اعتقد بانه سيصمد
اي عائق الان او امام اي وضع في السياسه
البريطانيه
رئيس الوزراء مرتين خلال اربعه اشهر
وكيف ابي التعليق اذا رشي مثلا احدث فوضى
او تسبب بكوارث فكيف سنستبدله
فسنخسر كل الشريعه الضروريه فيها
الانتخابات المقبله وكيف اي شخص بحزب
المحافظين المشكله حزمه حافظينه مهما فعل
الريشيتا يجب ان يدعموا وهذا يجعله في مصر
قوي جدا فهو قادر على فعل كل ما يشاء
واشكوا بان حزب المحافظين سيتمكن من
استبداله